Hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Subnautica.
Now there's been a number of changes to the game.
There's been a full new update that's actually been released
that involves a lot of small things
but also a lot of big things as well.
You may now notice like the icons are now a lovely shade of blue
and they have the distance marker that they are actually in the ocean
And that's applied to everything
and including this thing
If I was further away you'd be able to see that
but I'm going to dock right now because I just got done gathering
some extra titanium for the road
AND I'm going to FINALLY
be able to start a fricken episode with me putting names on the lockers
as I was supposed to do since the beginning of this.
So I have got enough to be able to make
three more lockers
riiiiiggghht...
background sound effect
Why can't I put you there?
I was promised a double decker
Ok I gotta do-- there we go
It's just gonna be a litte off center, you know?
My lovely organizational skills
ain't-- ain't coming too good
and I dunno why those are darker than the other ones but ok.
OKAY so the first commenter we got on here is  Marryal Mandy 14 who said:
"Hey Mark, don't mean to burst your bubblebut but you can't take your Tiny Box Tim with you those 900 meters.
With the Seamoths inside the Big Box Barry you can only go as deep as the Seamoth.
You can take your Seamoth out and put the Prawn suit IN though. Then you shouldn't have a problem.
Hope I could help."
(back to Mark) Well that's sad because that means that I gotta leave Bubblebutt over by the moon pool that I got over in the deep end.
But I guess that's ok, I was gonna take the prawn suit down there anyway
and I still gotta make the modification station to be able to even GO that far down
because one of the other things that they updated in this version of the game
is the fact that they've actually added in the precursor base into the lava castle area.
And I don't know if that advances the story but I haven't even made it down below that weird brain tree thing
So I gotta go down there first, all the way to the bottom of the Lost River
and THEN I gotta go explore the inactive lava zone
and what happens when I do that I have no idea but there's been an official update.
And I'm going to get to the details of it later but next up is SoWasRed/SoWasRead (?)
And they say:
"What I would really love to see is if you moved your KeyComm space kitty poster on to Big Box Barry.
It may not be all that helpful for the progression of your game, however it will be helpful to keep your sanity
while astray in the depths of the ocean that is a sea full of deadly creatures and eerie noises!
Couldn't hurt! MIGHT HELP!
And it would be a cute little addition to your submarine.
Also you can have a constant reminder of how all your friends and family crashed and burned in the Aurora,
not even the Sunbeam could save you: Survivor Guilt :)"
So that's a uaaahh--
aaaauuuh-- that's a--- that's a real happy--
happy comment there thank you so much for that that's awesome.
Always glad to be reminded how many people I know are dead.
And then next up is Jonas Grapperson (?) who says:
"I normally only yell while I'm watching football matches
but you've just made it onto my list when you built the Big Barry in the shallows. Congratulations!"
Aah, eh, that's just because I like to live dangerously.
and also because Jeffrey Billy Samwise and Marshall are a bunch of idiots and they don't know how to build things when they're supposed to build them.
SO!
With that being said we've got some other things that we need to do.
I-- whoauh--
Why is everything I build all greyed out?
But anyway there's been some quality of life imrpovements
I can actually make a trash can that can throw things away permanently
I don't have anything that I want to throw away but I-- I can make that now
And also the coffee machine in my base works!
And I'm gonna go down there and get a coffee, and APPARENTLY you can also build a vending machine
that supposedly gives you a steady stream of food and I'm not sure about that I gotta go scan a vending machine if that's the case
Oh I CAN make a vending machine! I'm gonna try to make that.
If I can make that in my... if I can make that in here that'd be awesome holy shit.
And I can make a bed but I'll make that later. Maybe I'll put that here.
Maybe I'll just make this, Big Box Barry, my mobile home and-- and I'll never even need to go anywhere ever again.
It'd be great I could have a water filtration machine--
I can put power machines on my Big Box Barry
that are going to be able to charge it but first, before I do any of that,
I need to make a modification station.
I literally can't do anything else until I'm able to get that modification station.
If I don't have that I'm literally going to be lost because I can't go any deeper.
So, above all else the modification station can actually enhance the pressure compensator into the
Ultra Cyclops Reinforcement Module and allow that to go deeper
in ADDITION to the fact that it can make the depth reinforcement for the Prawn Suit go down 2 additional levels
so it can go down to the absolute deepest that it could go.
And I gotta do that by gathering a bunch of materials
I've got all the plasteel.
Or at least I've got all the titanium ingots and I just need to get, uh, lithium to be able to do that
But next up--! Where's the Fuck is the modification station?
ooOOOOOHH NOOOOOOO
(despairing) I DON'T HAVE THE MODIFICATION STATION
WHERE THE FUCK WAS THAT?
OOOOH NO.
Ah shit.
Alright so supposedly the modification station is in the Grand Reef which is where my base is anyway
so what I'm gonna do is I'm going build one additional thing right here right now...
which is where and when and how...
I'm gonna build a growbed.
Oh no that's an exterior growbed sorry.
An indoor growbed which I can put here
I could put it right here, by my driver's seat, so that I can have TREES WHEN I DRIVE.
Is there any place to put a nuclear reactor say?
Per se?
Anywhere? No?
Seems like a big negative one this one.
Can I put you on here?
Just gonna put a nuclear reactor on the roof it's gonna be great
Gonna look good
Okay this isn't working
Ok, excuse me, I gotta-- I gotta move this, I gotta manoeuvre this.
*Markiplier noises of exertion*
WATCH OUT! LOOK OUT BELOW!!
LOOK OUT! Oh, shit.
Oh look out, me. Look out world.
Apparently there's no more automatic deformation of any of the materials which is, uh,
like the land cannot be changed
and supposedly that's gonna create a lot more stable environment for the game
which I'm looking very much forward to because I--
anything to make the performance of this game better is good in my book
if it takes away deformation of the environment that's totally fine.
Uh, the terraformer was removed a long time ago just because that was causing bugs like crazy.
BUUUT
Before I'm able to go anywhere--!
oh
*deep foghorn sound*
(Mark sort of imitates the sound) WHHEERGH?
Hello?
Hi!
I'm finally as big as you are.
Hi!! We're communicating!
Hello!
Oh you got more pulsating sacs than I remember you having
Yeah they seem to be a lot more mobile and--
and supposedly they're supposed to be able to call in response to this horn
*foghorn sound, Mark imitates (badly)*
HHHEEEEEAAAAARH
HELLOOoO?
FRIEND?
Uuuugh don't look at me, don't look at me friend, I actually don't want to look at you. Ok.
Alright then.
But first things first I need to put solar panels on this bad boy and I should have enough
ooh...
I should have enough titanium to be able to do that
Whoah oh NO IT'S NOT MATING SEASON
WHOOOOOA
HEY HEY HEY HEY
BACK AWAY
BACK AWAY SONNY JIM
HEY!
NUHNO--
(admonishing) DON'T NUZZLE ME!
OH DON'T YOU NUZZLE BIG BOX BARRY
You're not good enough for Big Box Barry
Ugh
God Damnit stop trying to mate with my--!
Oh what have I done?
Ohh fuck!
STOP TRYING TO HUMP MY SHIP! ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
UUUugggghhh...
I've AROUSED it.
Okay lemme jus--- oh fucking hell dude! Jesus!
WHADI--?
WHAT DID IT DO TO YOU DID IT SPURN YOUR ADVANCES?
OOH FUCKING Come On Man it's not worth it
OOohhhh just let it go! She doesn't like you!
Big Box Barry doesn't like you, it's a lost love!
Oh man who am I to sp--
*Beep* Alert: "30 seconds"
Mark, quietly: Huh?!
ooh...
Whoaahhh I like that! New alert.
Anyway, who am I to stop lost love?
Lemme just get this done so I can go back in
Hey, stop   humping around
Where do I put this thing?
I was told I could put this on this.
I was told this.
I was informed this.
This is not true apparently.
*Beep*
Alert: "Oxygen"
(Mark mimics in a husky voice) Oxygen
Thanks for telling me Karen
Aah-uh-FUCKing-ewhooaahh-uhheyy
Okay, so--
BBB: "Welcome aboard captain"
Mark: Thanks, uh--
BBB: "All systems online"
Eeeuuuh you might want to, y'know, not do that
So what I gotta do is I gotta th-- I gotta get the materials necessary to be able to make the modification station
which I think the only thing I'm gonna need is a little bit ooooffff--
WHOAHH sorry!
Sorry, that was NOT--
THAT WAS NOT BIG BARRY'S DONGER
DON'T GET ANY WILD IDEAS ABOUT THAT I SEE YOU--
--'VE BECOME VERY PROLIFIC
I SEE REEFBACK BABIES ALL OVER THE PLACE
But you don't need to worry about that
Just--
Okay, I'm gonna leave you two alone for a little bit
I just don't want to come back and s-- (trails off)
--things to be horrifically ruined.
Just please. Calm thy tentacles.
*snarling noise*
Uh-oh.
Who's gonna bite my bu-- oohhh heyy wow
Everyone's getting really frisky this time of year.
Holy god damnit I don't need gold
THERE we go I need silver
Am I full up? Yeah I'm full up.
Ok that should be enough.
I'm running low on calories anyway so I gotta get back and eat, drink, and hopefully--
Hopefully Big Box Barry-- where you at where you at where's--? Ah, there you are!
The cool new symbol that points you out
Hopefully Big Box Barry isn't, um... HUMPed to death by the Reefback.
I mean Big Box Barry's tough but you know... he's only got so much stamina left in him.
(Mark grumbles)
OHH GOD THEY MADE A BABY
OHHOH GOD
OH NOOO!!
THEY MADE A BABY
YOU WEREN'T THERE BEFORE!
HIIIii!
What are you tired?
Alert: "Emergency: severe dehydration detected"
Mark: Momma tired?
Oh boy..
Alert: "Emergency: severe dehydration detected"
Well that's no good
(Alert continues, unintelligible)
That's no good that's no good at all....
So anyway!
I, I gotta figure out, like--
Alert: "Starvation iminent"
I remember there being a way--
(Mark talks over alert) Ohh whatever, Karen, you're always so worried about me
It's silly even
Yeah I remember there being some sort of uhh... some sort of a mechanism by which
I could get power on this or at least that used to be a thing.
They may have changed that, but I was pretty sure you were able to make
like, at least a solar panel on the roof of it so that when you breached water
you were able to get some power from the Sun, but I guess it's...
Maybe it's a bit harder now which
is good question mark?
[[Note: he actually said "question mark"]]
I dunno
Okaay and then glorf... Blef?
Alriiight! That'll do me.
And I've got lots of thiiis
Okay so I should be able to maaaaAAAaake
SchuhBAM and the wiring kit
Both of those is good for me!
I got three silver, right? I better have gotten three silver if I didn't get three silver--
GOOD--
Wiring kit.
And then two titanium and you got yourself a modification station
But I don't even have the plans for a modification station
So NOW, we must--
Bye!
Oh.. Barry, I'm-- I'm sorry...
I'm-- I'm so sorry you have to say goodbye to your love.
I mean, who am I to stand in the way of this?
Uhh....
eugh...
eugh..
uogh...
ugghh
ugh
Man everyone wants a piece of action here
ALRIGHT. GOODBYE.
(Mark blows a kiss) Smooches
It was a wonderful time but we gotta get outta here
We just-- we gotta go... we got-- we got things to do
Oh, yep, one last call into the darkness
Oh that-- oh my God that one is infected
Whoahh it's glowing green holy shit
*foghorn noise*
(Mark imitates) HEEEUUUURGH
I just gotta make one pitstop on the way back for some lithium
but other than that I think I'm good.
*quiet foghorn noise*
Goodbye! Goodbye!
(Mark blows a kiss) Mwah!
Big Box Barry the handsome beast is going back into the darkness
You won't see me for a long time, ladies
(faux macho voice) Don't worry, I'll stay handsome
(faux macho voice) I know, I know, seems impossible but
(faux macho voice) maybe I might even be MORE handsome than the last time you saw me
(faux macho voice) I know! I know! Impossible! I know.
(faux macho laugh) hahahaaha
If-- If I'm not mistaken there seem to be more Reefbacks than there've ever been in...
As beautiful and pulsating as they are I-- I'd rather be left alone
and-- and I think Big Box Barry needs some, you know, some-- some him time
just Bro Time, you know?
just some...
The Boys.
And also Bubblebutt back there
We got our own baby to worry about so, no thanks.
This is where some lithium is so I'm going to go..
out in Bubléboat
and then hopefully be able to do something of that nature
That's all that I seem to be able to get.
If I need more I'll come back with--
OOOH!!
EYYY
One last gift for the road yes please
Thank youu
Alright.
So that seems to be all that I'm able to get for right now so I'll come back with Mister Fister if I need more
but seven, plus what I got in my uhh,
my stores PLUS what I've already made out of plasteel
or what I've made into plasteel, should be
JUST ENOUGH
And thusly all I need to do now is get this shit
Bubblebutt: Welcome aboard Captain. All systems online
And then I gotta remember that I got stuff in Bubblebutt (mumbles) but that's for another day
Sooo
Yeah! I got five lithium so if I just put this lithium in there I'll take this bar of gold out
and dump...
This'll be the lithium locker for now
We've got enough to make every single titanium ingot in here into a plasteel ingot
And then with some spillover titanium over there
We should be in really good shape!
I think, anyway. I'm hoping we're in really good shape, but that doesn't mean it's going to be true
cause usually whenever I have goals and dreams they get snuffed out right in front of my face
so I'll see how that turns out in the deep dark ocean shall we?!
(nervous laughter, trails off)
Ay ay ay....
(Loftily) Oh here we are again...
Oh the familiar places indeed!
I remember..
The last time I had my Cyclops down in the darkness I remembered the distinct problem
of NOT BEING ABLE TO SEE A GODDAMN THING
Ohh hi, well, you are Not supposed to be there
What're you gonna do? I'M IN MY CYCLOPS - and I can magically see through my base - but that's the least of my concerns right now!
Because Fuck You that's why
Fuck You.
You think you're COO~OOL??
Huh?
You can't get me.
Not here! Not now.
But just to be safe I'm gonna pilot my Seamoth into my base
and then hide out there until it's time
to go look for the plans for the modification station
Seamoth alert: "Caution: passing safe depth"
Mark: (urgently) Eyayayayaaaayyayay
Oh boydeeboydeeboydeboydeboyde
Heyy ho! Let's all go!
Yeesh.
But I know he can't get me in here
And my Cyclops is safely right outside
But supposedly
Does this work?
Use?
*sped up Markiplier squeak*
What is it doing?
What are you doing??
Ohh I didn't put a cup there
I mighta wanted to put a cup or something
HMM
(Excited) OOOH!!!
What??
Ohh!
Oh that's awesome!
It's only four but it's something!
I mean I've got the water filtration systems here so I don't really need, you know all that much but
still that's-- that's frickin' awesome!
That's so cool!
I mean I got plenty of water, again, I don't really need it but...
Still...
Oh that's awesome!
That's soo cool!
I can make co-- I don't know why that's so cool that shouldn't be that cool but it's cool - I can make coffee!
The uh other thing that I can do that's gonna be really really cool is - not that one--
--but this one.
I can make an interiorior growbed [sic]
Wow
(slowly stresses syllables) Interior growbed
(Mark noise) Heh!
HaaaaAABOOSKY!
And then I can actually legitimately plant trees in my Cyclops
so that I'll never have to worry about food and water down here again!
I-- I-- I think actually that's--
I'm pretty sure that's actually true because the lantern fruit provides a pretty equivalent amount of food and water
And you can only eat like ten of them at a time
I guess what happens if you eat too much is your stomach explodes and you die but,
that's besides the point
Let's not-- I'm not really worried about that-- these are pitch black now that's great. Okay. Good.
Good sign that they're becoming infected with some sort of horrible disease
So in addition to that I can pull this stuff out of here
I've got pretty much everything I need
But what I don't have - what I just Do Not Have - is a modification station
And SUPPOSEDLY
Supposedly
There's modification station fragments down here in the deep Grand Reef
So what I need to do
is I need to go find 'em.
There's really no other way about it I just gotta go down there and get 'em.
So if I can find, like, a wreck of some sort that would be good.
OHHh my GOD
Is that titanium-- Did they finally add titanium ingots?!
Or deposits down here?
(Relieved) Finally!
In the new updated I think they might've done that because I've never seen that before in my life!
Whooah this is going down-- OOOH that's going down too far!
Whoah what is that?
Did I reach the end of the road?
Oh I uh might've actually found the end of the world
Oopsie doopsie
Well this seems bad again I seem to have found another way down into the depths of Hell
Oh boy!
Don't know if Imma able to get out of this one
Can you please--? Thank you.
Whoah
Hokay so I'm really close to the precipice of destruction here and I don't like it very much
(Singing) I get knocked down, but I get up again
(Singing, slurring unintelligibly)
(Singing, slurred) I GE~t knocked DOo~Wwn
But I get up again~
(Weird voice) They're never gonna keep me doowwn~
(Another accent) I hear dat guy. He come after me
He gonna get me dead a lot.
(French(??) accent?) I don't like him
He's an asshole
(Irish(??) accent, now trailing off) Don't want him to be alive...
(Back to normal voice) I'll grind ya
Gonna grind ya
Griding.
Grind, get ground, get ground, get ground, I'm gonna grind you up
Yeeaah that's right you better run
Think you could fuck with me the answer is Maybe
The answer is a solid mmmprobably
AAAH!
AHAAAAHH!!
Fucken FINALLY!
JEEZ-UMS
I've been wondering around for like 20 minutes trying to find you you Mister Piece of Bouchey Douche
ALRIGHT
FINALLY
Jeez
At least I got a good idea of the Grand Reef now
I wasted ten years of my time doing it
So!
Somewhere hidden in this mess
iiis a moonpool fragment
And I'm gonna find it
What?!
The fuck?
What the fuck is going on
Ookay, DON'T FUCK UP PLEASE
(Quietly) What the fuck are you doing?
What??
*Metallic clanking*
What?
*Beep Beep*
Alert: "30 seconds."
There's two doors what the fuck?!
OH COME ON IT'S OUT OF BATTERY?
OH, FUCK OFF
Why didn't I just open this one?
What is this, The Labyrinth of Doors?
Oh GOD IT IS
JEEZUMS
Oh MY GOD! NOOoo! DON'T SEAL ME IN HERE WITH YOUR MAGIC FUCKING DOORS
Oh my God it did.
It sealed me in here with it's Magic Fucking Doors.
OH MY GOD
DO NOT DROWN ME
(Becoming frantic) DO NOT DROWN ME DO NOT DROWNMEDONOTDROWNME--
Prawn suit: "Welcome aboard Captain."
Mark, relieved: OHHh Fucking Fucking Fuck.
What the-- I don't have an extra battery!
God Damnit
Are you fucking kidding me I finally make my way down here
and I don't have an extra fucking battery for my laser cutter
It--
It took that much power?
I've no idea this is obviously a bug but I--
I'd like to think that it's just cosmically
the game doesn't want me to do this because now I've been recording this episode for an hour and 20 minutes
just trying to find the damn thing
get everything in order
(Quietly) Ohh...
Please don't tell me I have another door-- what is this--
OH GOD I don't know if I have enough oxygen for thiiiis!
But I'm going anywayyy cause I'm--
Oh ffffff-
--ucking come ON!
ANOTHER one are you kidding me?!
*Beep* Alert: "30 seconds."
I get it yeah I get it
Jesus Christ...
It's gotta be joking
Two down...
*metallic clanking*
Please tell me what is that?
What is this?
Found a-- Gimme that, gimme
Abandoned PDA - good
Okay I gotta go get oxygen and then I'll come back
So let's do this! Come on please tell me there's no things I gotta cut down left...
Just give me a modification station and let me be on my way!
Is that really all there was? There's no modification station here.
It was all a lie
It was all a goddamn LIE
WHY?!
For what purpose?
Why is this all here if there's nothing to go for it?
I mean, just, there's another bed here but it's already a bed I've got!
(Exasperated) Well goddamn it!
Was the modification station fragment only outside this thing, and not actually inside the thing?
Because holy shit if that's true... then what the fuck.
So what did this PDA say what was so important?
Data downloads, operation logs, surveillance: leisure deck
" [Passenger 1]I just came on board I was visiting my daughter. She was married a-- She married a Mongolian
now they're with one of those awful mining operations."
"[Passenger 2] I've been on board since Alterra space.
My institute paid for the full journey as a research initiative."
"Passenger 3] I'm just here for the experience - you can do all the VR you like, nothing compares to the real thing."
"[Passenger 4] You mean you're here for fun? For 18 months? Are you crazy?"
"[P3] What's crazy?"
"[P4] You're paying to stare at empty space."
"[P3] That's not what I'm paying for. I'm paying for the adventure."
"[P1] What adventure?"
"[P3] The sort of adventure money can't buy. Life. This. Discovery."
"[P1] I'd rather discover the Martian Beach Resorts myself."
Mark: Huh.
Whoever Passenger 3 is...
suurely didn't get the adventure they were hoping for
unLESS I'M Passenger 3
Unless-- Maybe that's me! Maybe that's MY operational log and that's actually this character here.
I'm not part of this company, I literally just paid to go on an adventure and somehow..
this is what I got to show for it, so...
Anyway
Holy shit what the fuck, then?
Did I already get all of the moon-- uh, modification station fragments from this wreck?
WELL... that was a bust...
But, at least, there's another
there's another wreck
I know that to be certain. There is another wreck.
Whoah
WHOA OKAY
Ohhhh yeah
That worked out surprisingly effectively
You latch on and you don't let go
I'm gonna wr--
Dosedo...
Docedo...
(Quietly) Where you at?
(Very quiet) That's right...
WHOAH hey WHOA WHOA WHOA RIGHT IN FRONT OF MY FACE
HOLY SHIT
FINALLY!
I haven't even found the wreck yet!
Hohh my God!
Why was that so hard to find?!
And I found one of 'em.
What the Fuck I feel so good now!
Prawn: "Welcome aboard Captain"
God you guys have No Idea how long I've been waiting to find that
I've been wandering and wandering for the past HOUR
Or more, actually, more than an hour
I've been wandering around
just looking for that.
But where's the wreck then?
God, there's just a fragment sitting out in the open like that jeezums
OHH IT'S RIGHT IN FRONT OF MY FACE HUH
GODD
DAMNIT
FUCKING *FINALLY*!
JEEZUM CHRISTMAS COOKY COCKS
Slow
Alert: "-starvation iminent"
Mark: C'm'ere
(Talking loudly over alert) I KNOW STARVATION IS IMINENT.
I'M TRYING TO SOLVE THAT.
NOT THAT NOTTHATNOTTHAT GET IN IT
YOU FUCKIN' ANNOYA-- NO!! GET IN IT! NOOO!!!
Gah fucking God damnit
I don't have the patience for this!
I don't have Time for this
I WANNA BE DONE WITH THIS EPISODE BUT I
(shouts) *PROMISED*
I would fucking get the modification station
and that's all I promised to do
so I'm gonna do that.
God damn it I *cannot* believe-- I cannot BELIEVE
how much Effort
it has Fucking taken to find a fucking modification station
AND I STILL HAVEN'T DONE IT YET
I FOUND ONE. I NEED *ONE MORE*!!
Oh no you don't, oh no you don't, you want to fuck on me, huh?
NOOoooO
Gett-- Ohh yeah you're gonna get-- ooh you're gonna get shredded!
Nah-nah-nah-nah yeah get outta here, okay.
Jeezums
Oh Myy Godd, I cannot believe this.
I've been recording for a total of an hour and 40 minutes for *one* episode.
Oh fuuuu-- (devolves into wibbling sound)
Okay please, I'm begging ya
I'm begging you here
I wish I had a flashlight but I don't
I wish...
Oh where is this taking me this is a long way down
What is this?
A PDA?
Really?!
That's IT?!
NOOOOoOOOO!!
Ohh that can't be it...
The fuck is thi--
THERE WAS A WAY IN?
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?!
Are you kidding me? Where is my goddamn Seamoth - oh God it's over there
Are you kidding me?
There was a way in the whole time and I did not need to cut a single goddamn door.
I coulda gotten to that PDA at any moment
Oh boy!
So happy about that...
Fuck, and I took the long way around
Am I gonna make it?
*Beep beep*
Alert: "Oxygen."
Mark: Oh God no
Oh please--
WHY AM I SO SLOW?
I DIDN'T USED TO BE THIS SLOW
MY GOD!
HOHH FUCK this is so stressful!
WHY GO-OD DAMN-IT!
Fuckin where's the modification station?!
What was in the PDA?!
Public documents - Torgal Corp?
"Torgal Corporation is a long-standing family-run business that operates almost a dozen mining and trading operations.
"The company share price hit an all time high on the announcement by a cabal of Mongolian inerests of
"[their interests of] their intention to construct a new phasegate utilising Torgal materials.
"These plans were put on hold when Bart Torgal, the intended leader of the new mining operation, disappeared along with his father."
(Mark sighs)
Are those the two people from the Degasi?
Is that how that ties in?
Ohh no...
I know you guys have been yelling at me probably for the past
however many minutes this cuts down to but please, take it easy on me.
I did not look it up
The last time I remember there were modification station fragments in the Grand Reef
and I naturally assumed that they would be by the wrecks
(Softly, Mark sounds heartbroken) but they're not.
Please go easy on me you don't understand how crushed by soul is right now
I might be smiling but I am in agony
I have been wasting
an hour and 30 minutes of my time
looking for these wrecks that shouldn't have been this hard to find
and then spending so many resources trying to get in them - when in reality...
I was in the wrong zone...
*Heartbroken, disbelieving silence*
I am the broken shell of a man formerly known as Markiplier
(Quietly, voice breaking) I have nothing left inside my soul.
(Quietly, voice breaking) I am a dead man.
(Even quieter, voice still broken) I am in pain.
(Pained) Ohh I'm in such agony I started this episode with such High Hopes!
I started thinking that this would be a good Fun Time!
FOR FUN TIME MARKIPLIER FUN TIME FUN!
I was gonna have so much fun--
I need a coffee
(Mark groans)
(Still pained) Ohh man this is the most harrowing adventure of my life and it's all an instrument of my own doing!!
I'm in a hell of my own creation!
(Weakly) Give me coffee...
I need to make a battery!
Aah I only have one acid mushroom
I don't know if those exist out here I think they do-- Oh good I got more
I've also got dead batteries because I've never made a battery charger!
That's also my own fault!
IIIIII Fucking hate life!
(Mark Groan™ sound)
Fuck
Ohhh my God, I am in s--
My-- I am  soooo sorry
I am in SUCH PAIN
OHHHHH GOD I'M A BROKEN MAN
WHAT HAVE I DONE?!?!
Oh, fuck...
Ayayayyay...
I promised that I would get this modification station
if it's the last thing I do
Base: "Welcome aboard Captain"
and I intend to keep my Promise.
Hhayayay--
But I'm gonna have to take this to get down there because I'm pretty sure the Blood Kelp Zone is deeper
Ahh! Oh. I found it, I found it, I found it.
Oh my God I found it
Hooohhh my God I found it
So supposedly in this wreck--
in THIS WRECK--
there is
a modification station fragment.
I am beyond
ready to kill
I am *far*, FAR, far beyond ready to kill
Ffucking WHOOO did that?!
FUCKING FUCK OFF, MAN!
I'VE HAD ENOUGH!
I'VE HAD ENOUGH DONE TO ME!
I'M SO TIRED!
I just want to go home!
I just want to be done!!
I just want to *do* this, and I want to *leave*,
and I want to go *home*
I want my Mommy
(Quietly) Please, I am *begging* you...
I am Begging you just give me
a fucking fragment,
and I'll be on *voice breaks* m-my way
I'll just go
I'll never bother another living creature in Subnautica
I will live a happy life if you can just give me
Alert: "Caution--"
one...
Alert: "--calorie deficiency detected."
(Softly) oh no
(Softly) no...
(Softly) no.....
I have no joy left in my soul
If there is Not
If there is not a moon pool fragment in there--
And I am *once again* moving VERY SLOWLY
If there isn't...!
What do I do?
What does it WANT FROM ME?
WHAT THE FUCK DOES THIS GAME WANT FROM ME?!
Just PLEEAASE, I am BEGGING you!
ONE FRAGMENT!
JUST ONE!
*PLEASE*
I AM BEGGING YOU!!
ONE FRAGMENT!
ANYTHING!
*Courtesy of Mark's plea for "anything", the Warper appears*
OH FUCK OFF-- DO NOT-- PLEASE!
God damnit do not!
Alert: "30 seconds"
Ugh!
Hhohh man!
(Softly, voice broken) I'm just a broken man
I looked - in every nook,
in every cranny in there - I've looked.
And unless I overlooked something - and I'm not in the mood to be overlooking anything right now--
It wasn't in there.
*Why* it's not in there, I have no idea
But every wreck that I've seen
thus far,
In the past three wrecks that I've been to, have had nothing scannable.
And I don't know what that's about
But that is just what I am dealing with right now
This is like
This is like the end of a movie where someone's hopeless journey just carries them to the edge of the abyss
and they fall in.
I promised
I would find this thing
And the only thing I have left is to hunt--
Seamoth: "Welcome aboard Captain"
--in the unknown,
which is basically what I've been doing
For some reason every wreck that I've come across has nothing in it
No-- N-no resources, no scannables, nothing but one PDA--
Alert: "Caution - passing safe depth."
Mark: --in every single one of them
And I don't know why
I honestly, truly do not know why
All I know is that the *only* thing I have left
is the Hope
Just the raw, unfiltered *Hope*
that I can find one, somewhere...
(Quietly) The last thing I need to deal with right now is a Leviathan...
But there's a wreck to the northern end of the
fucking
mountain...
*Bang*
AH!
FUCKING GOD--
DAMNIT
*Beeping alarm*
WHY?
*Beeping alarm continues*
Well you silent piece of shit let me go!
Do Not.
DON'T
Just fucking let me go...!
And I will be on my fucking way!
And you NEVER. FUCKING. BOTHER ME EVER AGAIN.
I don't know why--
--I didn't take out my cyclops
I know why, I know why
It wasn't due to negligence it was in the hopes that I could do it quickly
because I'm so tired I've been recording for three hours and 15 minutes now
I had so much more I wanted to get done today I had so many more videos I was gonna--
*Bang*
(Mark gasps loudly)
*Leviathan roars*
(Quietly) Fucking...
*Beeping alarm*
*Leviathan roars*
(Quietly, defeated) Let me go, please
Don't kill me
Don't kill Bubblebutt
I need him
He doesn't deserve this
He doesn't deserve my negligence
All I want,
All I've ever wanted in life is just one more modification fragment
And I have no idea where to get it
And the only hopes that I had was to go to the mountain wreck, and I can't even get to it
and the only means to do it is across the entire map
I'm physically in agony over this I--
I can't stand it and I just *have* to get it done, I can't stop until I get it!
And I don't even know if it's over there!
I might take my Cyclops over there for *nothing*!
If it's not there-- I'm banking a lot on this one wreck having something for me,
and there is no guarantee that it's gonna be there, because every single wreck that I've found
has had very minimal things for me!
There's been a few Prawn Suit things
I've gotten things for the one thing I hate the most, which is the Prawn Suit
And *ALL* I'm asking for is the modification station because I legitimately cannot stop
Because if I stop I'm NEVER GOING ANYWHERE IN SUBNAUTICA
I HAVE TO HAVE THAT
IF I DON'T HAVE THAT MODIFICATION STATION--!
EVERYTHING. STOPS!
I can't continue the game!
I have to have it!
(Mark sighs) Oh man...
This better have it because there's nothing else I can do after this
This literally--
(Mark is speechless)
(Very quietly) I just don't know...
It was a quadruple door
It wasn't just a triple door, it was a fucking quadruple door
(Mark sighs)
(Quietly, bitterly) That's a grappling arm who gives a shit?
*Beep beep*
Mark: Oh Jesus
Alert: "30 seconds"
(Mark gasps)
Oh! Oh!!
OH! OH!!
OH! Where's?
God damn give me air!
Give me air! Give me Goddamn air!
Give me air!Givemeair!
OHH MY GOD!!
OH
OH NO
OH. OH GOD
OH GOD. SAVE. YES. PLEASE.
OhHHHH!!!
PLEASE DON'T BE A RUUUSE!!
Oh my God
Ohh my God OhmyGod
(Desperately and triumphantly)
OHHH MYY GOOOODDD!!!!
(Speechless joy)
OHHH
FUCKING FINALLY!!
OHH MY GOD!!!
**SUBTITLES 0:00-34:51 BY LECTIC**
**SUBTITLES  34:57-36:24 BY ANON, ADDITIONS AND EDITED BY LECTIC**
OOOHHHHHHHHHH!!!!
Huh...
Oh...
Ahh...
Ah..
Fuck
Ahh...
AAAHHHHHHHoohhh...!
Cyclops: "Welcome aboard Captain"
OHHH!!!
Cyclops: "All systems online"
OH MY GOD
OH MY GOD! SAVE!
*Insert Wilhelm Scream*
It took
Four.
Hours.
To find a modification station
But I did it.
And I'm done
I'm calling it a night
I'm hanging up my coat for now
I'll build it up in the next episode, but I've got IT
(Short sigh)
Things have changed
Since I started this
I've run every single thing I have out of power
I've even almost run my Cyclops out of power
Just trying to get this thing
But I did it
So with that being said
I will build the modification station in the next episode
And then we will dive... down into the depths and see what is at the heart of this place we call
Subnautica
So thank you everybody so much for watching, thank you for believing in me
And yes, I-- Maybe I looked over one, maybe I missed it,
maybe I was so exasperated that I didn't find it
But I cannot believe...
I just can't believe....
That--
--the world was just set out to get me
Cause it may have been easy!
I will readily admit I may have stupid about it, going about it the wrong way,
I have may have been a FOOL and overlooked it
There are a million ways that I have been a fool in this episode
but I got it...
And I'm going to relax
So thank you again everybody so much for watching,
And as always I will see you in the next video!
BUH-BYE!
*Delicate, sad piano music*
*Fart noise*